the city infested with crime disorder  and chaos there's one group dedicated to  upholding justice guilt bad news friends  a crime-fighting team a vaguely familiar  superheroes Superman I'm from another  planet but not Krypton boom door woman  nice  she's German and spider the Norden every  spider bitten by a radioactive man by  human senses tingling Aquaman and Batman  vampire Batman look out evildoers  because the fair use friends are ready  for action the freakiest friends are  facing multiple copyright infringement  lawsuits and are technically not ready  for action to be cut it to be continued  we're gonna see